What's up guys!
Welcome to another episode of Challenge Pongfinity
Today we will try out this cricket bat.
Leave your ideas and comments in the comment-section below!
I thought that you would be serving!
No, you are going to serve!
Let's try playing with a cricket bat!
How did you miss it?
That was alright...
That's a scary shot!
First base!
Okay, we are going to play a game of table tennis cricket.
You have to start running!
Do I get a point from hitting your shoes? No.
I did it! One point!
I think I broke the ball.
I think I was the winner of table tennis cricket!
I don't think so.
I was clearly the winner.
You can believe it yourself if you want to.